hey everybody its Jessie and today I'm
going to show you what I've done with
the our server das file with trying to
check to make sure our files are legit
before we upload them and we had a pool
request so Sebastian has done some work
on client side validation I'd like to go
over that I'm gonna try to get in to
Pomodoro cycles worth of coding today I
have a meeting in an hour and a half so
won't be super long stream today but I
think if we get into 25-minute Pomodoro
sessions and leave the rest of the time
for questions that that should
definitely be enough to get in all the
questions unless we have a lot more
questions than normal so I'm gonna get
right into it
if I notice that there's a lot of new
people in the live chat I might give my
normal explanation of what this is and
what's going on but otherwise to save
time I'm just going to get right into it
also have the Instagram live stream
going as well so if anybody's interested
in that not not really anything exciting
you just get to see my face in the view
of my office as if you were the monitor
okay so I just committed my latest work
and I'm gonna push it to the repo now
okay so that is now on the file type
check branch on the github repo the link
is in the description so if you want to
check this out on you know in the
browser or cloning the repo and and try
it out for yourself you can do that so
basically here's here's what I've done
and some of it might not be absolutely
necessary but I figured you know what
it's not like these checks are super
resource intensive so if I leave
something in that may not be absolutely
necessary I'm not that worried about it
maybe there is you know some some good
reason to have it in there that I just
can't think about in terms of a possible
malicious file upload so I'll just go
through some of the things you've
already seen at the end of yesterday's
stream I realized that I had made a
mistake and I was checking for basically
I was getting the file type the mi any
type but I was checking it against a red
jack a regular expression that had file
extensions instead so obviously like
that what it was working for pings but
it didn't work for pretty much
everything else and so that's why I
hadn't noticed it until the end so now I
have the correct checks but I've
actually I've kept both so I'm I'm
getting the file extension from the file
name and I'm checking that and I'm also
getting the file type and I'm checking
it against the M IME types so you could
see these are these reflect you know the
types down here so a little bit a little
bit longer okay but it's checking for
the same thing and I grabbed this from
what Sebastian was doing on the client
side and thank you for that Sebastian
because I was I was just getting ready
to get these and compiled something like
this on my
and then I saw your pool requests and
check that out and this just saved me a
bunch of time and trying to do this so
that was awesome I appreciate that
so I'm doing those two checks and you
can see right now I just have this if
statement that just has a bunch of
checks probably depending on what's
going on and how much time I have this
could definitely use some refactoring
and cleaning up in fact this entire
server das file is just getting really
long so it could it could use some work
I mean it's functional but it's not
pretty right now but I'm not gonna
bother cleaning it up until we get it to
the point where it's working like we
want it to work and then we can clean it
up if anybody really likes to do the
cleanup type of stuff
I appreciate and welcome any any pool
requests let me go with you other checks
okay so I'm checking I read up on node
security so let me show you what I found
so I found this article and I linked to
this here so you can check that out if
you look on the repo so this kind of
goes through some of the things that you
can do to help protect against attacks
from from file uploads and so I
implemented some of this one thing that
it was saying is you don't want to allow
dots and slashes in your file names so
I'm checking obviously we're gonna have
one dot for the file extension right so
I'm okay with one dot but anything more
than one dot I'm gonna reject so this
has dots here that's what it's checking
for so if has dots is true meaning it
has more than one dot then we reject the
file similar thing with slashes but I
don't want any slashes so if it has a
slash
then this will be true and we'll reject
it the other thing that I had never
heard of but I read about was this
poison no bites
so I'm not a hundred percent sure that I
understand how to do this right like if
I was in the place of the attacker I
don't know how I would do this but
basically it's a way to oops I need me
to click on that basically it's a way to
show one file name but that's not really
the real file name so you could have a
file name that passes all the other
tests but then really the file name
could be something that has like
something more like this down here that
has your dots and slashes that would
allow the user to access directories
that they shouldn't access ok so like so
I guess I understand what could happen
not really sure how is it to how to do
that but I've added a check for this and
so basically I just took this and now
I'm checking here for the it's a poison
and all bytes check so if this check if
this is true that means it's bad and so
we reject it so those are the that's
everything that I've added so far I I
think I think I'm probably gonna move on
at this point and do some more with
other parts of the site I need to get
this ready to show people in my
department and get feedback because
there's Pro there are probably going to
be some changes out of meeting this
morning department meaning and went over
some things
the Trello board which i think is linked
in the description has some new items on
there for changes to content and
additions to content so I'd like to get
some things working and make sure that
everything
at least visibly is ready for people to
give me feedback on so probably won't
work on this again until a little bit
later on but for now we do have some
decent checks and protections not
perfect but it's still not you know it's
much better than what we had just a few
days ago all right so now I'm gonna go
to the client side and I just realized
that I forgot to set my Pomodoro timer
so I'm about ten minutes in yeah I guess
I'll just set it and I also set it for
the full 25 and if we get down to it and
there's a few minutes left I may just
stop it a bit early so let me let me
just show you I'm gonna have to switch
let's see
let me check the live chat I just
realized that I hadn't even looked at it
at all yet so hey everyone
Oh Oscar says hello from Venezuela hey
welcome he says these videos have been a
great help to me thank you so much hey
you're welcome I'm really glad that
they're helpful to you that when I hear
stuff like that it makes me want to keep
going keep doing doing these videos so
that's awesome okay Sebastian said okay
here's some good stuff let me explain
this so Sebastian had a question here
and I want to explain this I forgot I
forgot that I did this so Sebastian's
version of this was a little bit bigger
so it had things like application so all
of them had this kind of first part here
and Sebastian was asking does it work
without that and it does if you do so
what I'm doing up here from my file type
is I'm only getting what's after that
slash right so that's why I was able to
leave off all the other things so if you
look at what Sebastian did on the pool
request
I think it's pool requests 56 yeah I
think 56 and I think it's Sebastian
actually a tool to pull request 55 did
get merged into master and that fixed an
error that was happening in the console
that had to do with IDs on input fields
so thank you for that Sebastian but
anyway that's why it works because I'm
not getting the entire file type I'm
splitting that and just getting that
last part
so either way would work it just depends
on what your you're checking it against
so in this case I'm checking it against
the file type which is just really just
the last part of the file type so
hopefully that makes sense okay cool
Sebastian says I got it yeah so sorry
about that I had four
didn't I didn't even remember that I did
that so yeah but like I said the other
way to work okay Sebastian also said he
doesn't think that he got all of them
skipped a few okay cool I'll just have
to go through actually I found a site
that has it it seems like it says that
it has all the different M IME types so
I'll go through and check it out it
looks like you you definitely got most
of them but I'll double check and go
through go through that site
okay so patrick has a few a few tips for
me here actually Sebastian poison the
lights
listen to my shake
Patrick when you said when you're
talking about the poison no bites check
I'm not sure what your your meaning
there when you have it twice with like
the little arrow in between it so I'm
sorry I'm just not understanding so you
get explain that a little bit more I
would appreciate it okay Patrick also
says Patrick says also I have multiple
dots and found in it's pretty often
which you should be concerned with this
double dots that's a really good point
oh did I just misspell poison is that
the problem okay I see it I see now that
it was spelled differently let me see P
man thanks for
okay thank you
that's funny yesterday I came home and
my wife said she was working on a free
code camp problem the one about
converting Celsius to Fahrenheit and
it's one of the early JavaScript dog
algorithms and she said she'd been
working on it for a long time I think
she said like 45 minutes she couldn't
get it to work so she wanted me to look
at it so I looked at it for a little
while and and probably just a few
minutes and I went through everything
and it was like yeah you know this this
should work what's what's going on and
she had just spelled Celsius wrong so
that was that was the problem she has
about two different ways so it kept
saying it was undefined inside the
function she was trying to pass in
Celsius as a parameter right and so
anyway that was the whole problem so and
I told her don't worry about it that
happens to me all the time in front of
everybody on YouTube so don't be don't
be embarrassed and here it just happened
less than 24 hours after that so anyway
I always appreciate that when when you
all catch that so I mean in this case it
wouldn't everything still would have one
run properly because I had misspelled it
consistently but it's still good
haven't spelled right
all right sorry about it I just kept a
bunch of messages this came up in my
slack for my department
I just wanted to skim through quickly
and see if there was some sort of
emergency it looks like
okay it looks like it's fine so alright
so I think we got we've got the spelling
sorted out I'll Det I'll go back and
double-check and make sure we're
covering all the types that we want to
cover here and now let me show you
what's going on with the client-side
validation so I'll bring this over so
you can see I'm gonna check out a
different branch so let's do check out
and I named this oops hold on a second I
have to get a knock at the door
okay I'm back let's see okay so I need
to check out to a different branch and I
can't remember what the name of that was
there we go okay so now we're on this
branch and I can bring over okay
so looks like it's working let me bring
this over all right so I'll show you
what it's doing first like what a user
would see and then we can check out the
code you can see the code I think I
mentioned earlier it's pool request 56
will show the the new code that's been
put in by Sebastian so you can see now
like if I try to put in numbers for my
name it'll say it's not a valid name
same thing email right so we have
immediate feedback which is pretty
awesome and also if we try to submit
without the required fields it says
right please fill out this field so
really useful it's it's nice to have we
also are checking types for the upload
so if I try to upload something that's
not supported it won't work so let me
see I'm assuming this isn't supported
let's see if this works
actually that's not working right now I
didn't test this out earlier so but I
know this is it's in there somewhere so
I guess I could try this I could try to
submit it but it's probably not gonna
work because we're on
I wonder what it happened okay so I
don't know how many of these Sebastian
made required but we need to go through
I still need to get confirmation from
people in my department as to what
fields really need to be required my
preference is to make as few fields
required as possible so that it's easier
for the user but I understand that there
are some things that are really
important to know ahead of time so we'll
see so I can't exactly complete this yet
and so I have that information I can I I
have most of the information to complete
these check boxes so that will be
happening soon and yeah I can definitely
at least get everything I know for sure
will be in here and then I'll get some
feedback on that but that's basically it
I mean it it may not look like a lot
right here but I'm sure as you know if
you've done something like this it's not
it's not just simple to do that there's
a lot that goes into it so let me show
you just a little bit about how this was
done so if we check out our package.json
you'll see we have formzee react in form
z material UI so this is really nice and
helpful there's already a library that
does validation and it integrates with
material UI so that takes care of so
much for us that was a really good job
finding that sebastian i i've a glee
remember looking into form z maybe
months ago for something and i
completely forgotten about it so i would
have tried to have done this completely
on my own had you know i found that and
that would have taken much longer so on
the service request form we're importing
things from form z and then using them
so our entire form then is rat this is
getting to be a big component huh
our entire forum then is wrapped in this
form z form component so a little bit of
a change in the way this this looks but
in terms of you know on this end of
things but pretty much everything inside
so I get about the same right we have
some some change right so form Z check
box right so we do have some things that
are at least for the words you know the
names of the components are slightly
different but not too not too bad in
terms of trying to implement this so
this is not it I'm just going over it
this is not everything that Sebastian
did so I'm going over this quickly so we
can move on to some other stuff but you
can see forms use a really good way to
do this and it's not like you don't have
to know a lot about form validation
yourself to implement some of this which
is really cool
okay
all right so let's check out what we can
do now on the Trello board so like I
said I'm going to kind of move this back
a bit and go go back to it just so at
this point I really do need some
feedback I think I could be moving
faster if I knew exactly what was wanted
um I'm kind of finding more things to do
or thank you trying to think of more
things to do until I get the info I need
and I haven't been super proactive and
trying to seek out the information you
know it's I much prefer to just be
sitting in my office coding I've been
trying to track down people and email
and get the information I need so it's
it's is partially my fault that I
haven't been been more aggressive at
that
actually this will be this might be fun
to do so I haven't done this before
so here's what I want to do so let me
show you where's our check boxes I don't
know if I should do it on this branch or
not probably not let's uh let's go to
another branch
this is going to be minor enough I could
think I could just do it on master it
should be fine
but let me just change one of these
checkboxes I want to change that to
photography great so here's what I want
to happen we have some additional
information that needs to be displayed
if someone selects photography so what I
would like to happen is when they select
photography have a modal come up or
basically if something needs to come up
and I'm not I'm not entirely sure what
the best thing would be right now my
initial thought was a modal and then I
thought oh well you know if that modal
pops up every time it's going to get
annoying for people who have read it
multiple times so then I thought perhaps
a tooltip right so that when you put
your cursor over top of it then it comes
up that that could work too it's not
it's it's probably a bit too much
information for a tooltip though let me
show you what the info will be just to
give you an idea so it's gonna be this
whole list
I think I'm originally I was supposed to
put the dates in here but I'm gonna now
they want me to leave out the dates so
this is going to be this big list of
events and then also some explanatory
text so I don't know I think that's way
too much for a tooltip I think it would
be better in a modal scrollable
especially like on mobile it's entirely
possible that this list could be bigger
than the viewport so I guess I'm
thinking more of a modal so that's what
I need so basically when this is checked
the modal needs to pop up and then the
modal can be dismissed but the check
would still be there so it's not going
to be tied
you know completely into the check in
terms of you know you can uncheck
certainly if you if you check the modal
needs to pop up but when the modal is
dismissed I want the check to stay there
right
Patrick's idea is how about an info icon
that pops the modal independent of the
checkbox the checkbox label I did think
of an info icon I'm okay with an info
icon I was kind of anticipating that
other people in my department would not
be okay with that but it might be worth
it just to put it in anyway and see if I
can find it by with that I think it's
better and less intrusive with the info
icon but from past experience with with
my department there they want to make
sure that people see things right so you
know they want there to be no question
that you know no one could come and say
well I didn't know you know they want to
be able to say well you had to have seen
it because you couldn't have gone any
further without seeing it right so if I
can get it through with the icon then
that's that's fine so let's do that
let's put add an icon and let's make it
so that if you click that icon then the
modal comes up it'll be independent of
the checkbox yeah I think that'll be the
best the best way to do it I also think
it might not be a bad idea if we have
time to add in in the email so if
photography is checked the email that
gets sent to the user confirming their
submission will also have that in
about photography and that way I think
we may get it may be okay to just have
that that icon there because they'll
beginning in a second time directly to
their email yeah so I think that sounds
sounds like it'll work let me check my
timer before we start on this okay let
me take my break now because if you
remember I started my time or nine
minutes late so let's let's take the
five minute break now I'm gonna go to
the Live Chat check everything probably
won't need the whole five minutes for
the live chat because there's not very
many questions but then we'll come back
and we'll we'll put this modal in so we
do have some modal's but I don't think
that I've done any modal's on on the
stream I think they're all from a pull
request so this will be cool we'll see
how to do modal's in material UI I don't
know probably not going to get to the
email thing like that'll be on the list
of things that if we have time we'll get
to but it's not really necessary
okay so let me go if you're not familiar
with how the stream works I take five
minute breaks between 25 minute coding
sessions to go to a live chat and answer
any questions that you might have after
the five minute break we'll go back and
do another session for today's stream
I'm just going to do two sessions totals
have one more session after this then
we'll finish up with a
question-and-answer session that is
normally as long as it takes to get to
all the questions today I do have a hard
break though because I have a meeting at
3:30 Eastern Time which is in about an
hour
all right so let me let me scroll up
okay Sebastian wanted me to share a link
to the security article all right I will
put that in the live chat now and it's
also a comment in the server JS file on
the the file file type check branch is
that what I called it I think so
yeah Jordan says what up programming
peeves hey how's it going thanks for
joining us
how cool sebastian said the first to do
is almost implemented yeah for sure
where did I put that
yeah anyway Sebastian I was like really
happy when I saw your pool request
because I was thinking like this is
going to take a long time for me to
implement
wait a second it says sebastian says he
can't find the pool request his pool
requests on github let me double check
which pool requests are you talking
about the one with the client-side
validation or the one before that so i
guess would be 55 or 56 oh you know what
that s client validation branch i did
not push that up yet so it's only exist
locally for me it's just a copy of of
your pool request and actually i think
it was before the last commit so it's
not even up to date so i'll need to pull
it down again to get the latest jonathan
says I've just started the responsive
design with bootstrap section on free
code camp I have no clue what's going on
here but I like that this is happening
all right cool
I'm glad you like it and feel free to
ask any questions I'm happy to answer
questions don't worry about if you think
the question is you know too simple or
something it's no questions bother me so
feel free to ask there's a lot of really
knowledgeable people people that know
more than I do in the live chat that can
help answer things as well sometimes it
takes me a little while to get to the
questions but I do try to answer
everything for the stream is over and
I'll try to explain things as best I can
as I go along
okay
all right I think I got that through
everything so okay not bad I didn't
think you'd take the full five minutes
but I got close so I'm gonna go ahead
and start this timer and let's do
another 25 minute session of coding when
I do these sessions it's not that I
ignore the live chat sometimes I check
back especially if I get stuck and need
to ask for some help but I just usually
don't answer questions during that that
period okay so the plan is make an icon
when you click the icon then the modal
comes up Sebastian I think had mentioned
maybe hovering over the icon and have
the tooltip up here I thought about that
too but like I said before I think it's
too much information for just a tooltip
I think a tooltip would have been ideal
if it wasn't for that giant list of
things that needs to that needs to go in
there so yes I think we're gonna go with
the modal hmm let's see how we can put
this in so right now we just have these
strings going in I don't know if I can
put in an icon but let's let's see if I
can put in HTML and see what it does
I'll just try this out first
okay can't like that see how this is
getting put in there all right so this
left check boxes
I wonder
all right let's try to do it like this
then instead of making it a string let's
put this whole thing in the span
let's see what we get
in the whoops
and I'm not working there
okay
all right so down here
down here we're doing some things with
that label and so that's not allowing us
to put in what we need okay let's see
okay so we need to find a way to pass
and let's say you think of some way
around it we need to be able to pass
HTML instead of a string which we may be
able to do but right now we are since
we're doing this
okay yeah we using this a lot all right
well let's take this off of the checkbox
you
all right so just for this checkbox
field just to test it I'm going to stop
this format label to property and let's
see
let's just put
all right hopefully it'll let me do this
just so I can test this out obviously I
don't want to keep it like this but this
should still work for everything else I
just needed to work for the checkboxes
all right let's see hmm looks like it's
not gonna work all right I'm not still
calling this somewhere
shouldn't be calling this anywhere else
let's double-check
all right so let's check it out that
string probs okay so that shouldn't be
doing it okay versus checkbox pros okay
we don't adhere to all right where are
we using checkbox probes
yes
alright I'm gonna I'm really gonna mess
this up
so I just want to test if this is even
possible before I make really big
changes alright let's see yes all right
awesome so it does work right so I
didn't do a great job explaining that so
let me let me kind of sum up what I did
the whole point of what I was trying to
do is that I wanted to see if I could
pass in HTML and have it render so I did
so I did here so you can see there are
spans here but they don't show up so
that's what we want so that works now in
the process of being able to do that I
had this disabled a lot of other stuff
that was going on so I may have made
this form at least the checkbox portion
of it useless and you can see since I've
just given all the checkboxes the same
name then the checks just keep the point
like this hold on one second everyone I
gotta take this hello hey how's it going
you
alright I'm back sorry about that
today's been crazy for interruptions but
that was I got a request to do some work
on a site that's not really one that I
maintain but we don't the position
that's supposed to maintain that is is
open right now we don't have anybody in
there so I guess I'm gonna do it and I
also got invited to a Labor Day picnic
so that's cool uh-huh
so let me see okay so I'm gonna catch up
just quickly on the live chat because it
looks like so Quincy's in the chat hey
Quincy if you're still in there
listening in the chat I did I emailed
you back right before I started the
stream so if you didn't get it I'll just
tell you basically my skype is just
Jessie dot Weigel and I'm available
today after four and then tomorrow after
four but also tomorrow I could probably
Skype between 11 a.m. and 1 p.m. and
that's all Eastern Time
okay
okay I think that's everything that I
need to catch up with ya yes
Quincy 4:00 p.m. Eastern Time today yeah
sorry about the email I mean I'm I'm my
almost positive that I said I definitely
typed it out and maybe I didn't stick
around long enough to see if it actually
sent but yeah just let me know okay I
have a short meeting at 3:30 p.m. today
so I think it should be over by 4:00
Eastern but it shouldn't run much longer
than that but anyway yeah just let me
know whatever time is good for you will
probably work for me as long as I don't
have a meeting or anything okay let's
see okay this is the best thing so so we
solved one problem that caused another
basically which is okay I knew that that
was going to happen when I was changing
things in there so let's see
before I go about changing this I want
to try to put in an icon just to be sure
that I can actually put an icon and it
then it works I don't see why it
wouldn't work but let's let's test it no
sense trying to rewrite a bunch of what
we're doing elsewhere in that component
if this isn't gonna work for sure so
yeah so we'll definitely need we need to
make sure I'm gonna try to use an SVG
icon hopefully that works we're gonna
have to make sure that we change the way
that this does click worst is right now
you can click anywhere on here and it
will check or uncheck the boxes so we're
gonna have to do something similar to
what we did down here except what I'd
like to do is have the word photography
still be clickable for the check but
then only the icon be what what brings
up the modal so if we can do that then
we will otherwise it'll be okay if users
have to just check on the box I would
imagine that most people's first
instinct is to check directly on the box
anyway I just glanced over and I saw we
have a question it says what are we
doing now what is this project basically
I am right now we're gonna add an icon
here on this checkbox and when you click
it it's going to open up a modal overall
the main point of the project is to have
a forum where people can put in requests
for work and then that form data gets
sent to our project management system
and then it also sends out several
emails to people one of them being the
user that inputs this data alright so
let's go back and well first let's grab
an SVG icon so let's check out the
material
there we go
here I come
all right cool so we have info I think I
like this one
and so outline SVG
and
we can just grab the code and I'm just
gonna put this right in here and see
what happens
see that works
Oh not bad it worked great okay cool so
we have an icon that's awesome
definitely needs some some positioning
work here but I'm not worried about that
yet awesome okay so we have our icon
let's see how did I do this before let's
see what I did down here
hmm maybe
okay alright so here's how here's how I
did this and here's how the check boxes
work and they have to come up with a
different way to do this then so the
input this would be easier to show it on
dev tools basically normally the input
is a lot wider right so it kind of goes
over so what I did was I made the input
width be a lot shorter so that's all I
needed to do to make sure that we could
click this and it would be a link
instead of just making the check box be
filled in so up here it's not gonna be
quite as easy to do
I mean right now we could I don't really
want to do it this way but this way will
work if we took these check boxes here
and instead of just having it be an
array it could be an array of objects
right and then we could have the check
box name or you know the label and then
also the value that we would put as the
style and then we have to change
everything we're doing well we're
actually we're already gonna have to
change the way we do this anyway so it
might not be that bad if we're gonna do
if we're gonna add this SVG in here we
can't keep it we can't keep this we're
gonna have to do something else
so that's a possibility the other
possibility would be let me try this out
so I haven't done this in a while but I
remember doing something like this
before that worked so we would go
no this won't work basically what I was
gonna do was go pointer events none and
then on the icon say pointer events all
oh sorry is yawning but that's not going
to work because then you couldn't
actually click the checkbox
hmm so I think the best bet is to make
this this checkbox just a lot a lot more
narrow yeah
all right I'm gonna go to the live show
if anybody has any suggestions other
than what I had just said that we could
possibly do let me know I'll just take a
minute to see what's in a live chat
before I try to implement any of this
because it's possible there's some
better solution that I'm overlooking
let's see
okay
okay John Hanson said I must prefer the
icon that is like an eye with an arrow
inside the box more - more intuitive - a
visitor as it says this will open
something up
I guess I'm open to different icons I'd
like to stick with ones that are like
material design that are normally used
with material design also ones that are
SVG so within that kind of with within
those constraints I'm open to having
different things
okay
man I don't think I'm gonna have time
since our second point Midori session is
almost over if anyone does have any
ideas about this at any point during the
question answer session that we're about
to have or later on or anything please
let me know because I'm just really like
I would hate to just change so much of
what's going on here just for one of
these checkboxes hum I mean maybe it's
possible that we would do similar things
with other checkboxes in the future but
right now there's there's no plans for
that maybe once people see this
then they'll request to have it on other
things I mean it could potentially be
useful there's just so much it's there's
so much potential for messing more
things up when I'm gonna cut and change
a lot of this but yeah I guess it it has
to happen that's I'm just not seeing
another better way right now okay so
that's the second Pomodoro session up I
guess we we kind of got some stuff done
not to the point where it it's it's
ready
obviously right we can't can't have that
but I think we're on the right track I
mean I know what I know it could be done
to to get it to work
so that's better than mean out of ideas
I suppose so I'm gonna go to the live
chat now if you have any questions
please put it in the chat I'll do my
best to answer it if if you can't stick
around and answer the question then you
can just direct message me
or watch the recording of this later on
if you were just here for the code and
you got a stop watching now that's cool
too thanks for watching I'll be back
again tomorrow I'm thinking tomorrow's
show probably be a little earlier maybe
like 1:00 p.m. Eastern 1:30 all you know
Oh course schedule it is early as I can
tomorrow and I'll put a message on
Twitter as well okay so I'm gonna go
through here looks like there's not a
whole lot in there so so if you are
going to answer your question I would do
it quick because I'm going to get
through these in a few minutes it looks
like
let's see I I'm on Mustafa hopefully I
pronounced that right sorry if I didn't
says you have followers from Egypt
awesome thanks for watching
Emmanuel says and follower from Haiti -
awesome thank you so much for watching
I'm on also said I'm front-end should I
continue watching yeah I'm I'm mostly we
mostly do front-end stuff so we have I
suppose been doing some stuff that would
be more back in the last couple of
streams but mostly we do front-end stuff
so this is definitely the right place
for you
oh okay you know what John just
mentioned something that I think this is
going to be a lot easier than I'm making
it out to be I think I was I was just
overthinking this too much so John says
can't the checkbox on that info icon
change the state of the modal and you're
entirely right it could definitely do
that so for whatever reason I was
thinking I wanted these to be
independent but I think when I initially
explained this I had explained that if
you check that a modal would come up so
what will happen like let's say that I
don't go through everything to make this
independently clickable from this what
will happen is if you click that I it'll
actually check this now potentially that
could be slightly annoying to user if
they just were curious about what this
was and didn't intend to check the box
but they could always uncheck it you
know it's not I guess it's not like a
huge inconvenience I could see that it
would be slightly unexpected but yeah we
could just have it so that a click on
here not only activates that checkbox
but it also makes the modal pop-up in
fact there may be some sort of callback
where we could we could make that happen
already but that kind of gives us the
same problem of how do we put that
callback just on this one and not on the
other ones without changing this into
some sort of array of objects for a
second I thought this would be a lot
easier but I guess it it won't be I
I guess the as it's set up currently
there's really no way around adding some
extra extra properties here
okay yeah so it may end up if I'm gonna
have to add add things to that array
either way I probably just should make
it happen whenever this is clicked and
making independent of the checkbox
Anheuser hey awesome
haven't haven't seen you in the live
chat for a while but said had the most
unproductive day today I'm sorry to hear
that sometimes that happens if you want
to want to give any details if you need
to talk about it that's cool
either in the live chat or you can
message me on Twitter if you want I
definitely definitely it happens so
don't get too down about it because
there there are some days when you're
super productive and some days when
you're not so productive but I'm sure
there's always something good to be said
for for any day
oh okay John Hanson says you can do
callback on key value yeah that's true
ACEF Lee true I'm gonna have to just
think about this more I I like I'd like
to take some time to just look at that
component as it is now and what all is
going on and rethink what what would be
the best way to organize this given what
we want to do now because when we first
made that we didn't have this in mind at
all so it's possible that it should
undergo a big change because the
requirements are different now and that
might be better to try to do a big
change and have it make more sense you
know from here on out in view of what we
may want to do not only with this
checkbox but with other checkboxes so
you're off to look at that I just I
haven't worked on this for well
basically since we first made it so I
need to like kind of reef Amil your eyes
myself with it and we have had some pool
requests with that as well so it looks
different than when when I was doing
things with it so yeah maybe I should
before I change any more and try to make
a big decision about it then I just need
to get to know what's going on
witch hunt says this is what can make
reactive at mind-boggling him yeah yeah
it can sometimes I saw I forget where I
saw it I probably either on Twitter
Instagram but somebody was saying react
makes simple things easy or complicated
things easy and easy things complicated
or something like that and I could see
yet like some things are really easy
with react and some things are like if I
was just using jQuery this would be so
easy but all in all I really do like
react I think it's worth it's worth the
occasional headaches to try to do a
thing that would otherwise be pretty
easy and in this case I don't
necessarily think it's Reax fault I
think it's just we had initially
organized this without thinking about
doing anything like this so you know
obviously it's it's not gonna work with
with it as is Sebastian says well I keep
updating my pull requests with small
changes not really following this dream
that's cool Sebastian I I'm not gonna
complain about that I definitely
appreciate the the pull requests and all
the changes so I mean I like having you
in the live chat as well but that's
definitely a great reason sonography
paying attention all right well I think
I've got through everything in the live
chat and I have all about about ten
minutes before I need to leave my office
and start walking over to the other
building where the meetings can be at so
thank you so much everyone for for
watching for joining in the live chat I
appreciate all the all the advice and
the suggestions that you have and all
the encouragement
I I'll be back tomorrow like I said
earlier it'll probably end up being a
little bit earlier than normal so maybe
like 1:30 p.m. Eastern Time yeah and oh
you know special thanks again to
everyone who who submits pull requests
and things as well that's that's just
super helpful and has helped me get a
lot better by reviewing you know all
this pull requests and seeing how you do
everything
all right yeah so I'll be back tomorrow
and until then have a great day